hey what's up y'all oh
hey what you guys playing oh no just a
little dvd right you know what dvd uh it
came for you in the mail it says to my
fresh dope son from m.c mom
i can't wait to see it
hey hey if there's one thing we're gonna
do today we are playing that dvd come on
come on man
oh yeah oh yes
oh god please man did you produce this
trash no no no no no no no no no
yo
oh
okay got on the bomb jeep
i'm the m to the c to the m o m and when
it comes to mom rappers i'm the bigger
the best of them
sending out this rhyme to my homie
number one his name's carl stewart but
to me he's just son
word up oh
okay she got that running man down come
on can we please turn this off
turn it up no yeah yeah i missed her
you left some stuff behind that i can
send you if you need like your best
friend bear and your magazines going
through all this stuff but it looks
pretty risky you use so much lotion but
your socks sure are crispy
i've been cleaning with the broom and
the vacuum and found victoria's secret
is she's hiding in your room every nook
and cranny there are wads of tissue i
can't even open this swimsuit issue
what is wrong with you bro i spilled a
soda on that magazine i'm getting your
sheets so nice and clean like when you
wet your bed till you were 16. i
overreacted sorry i spanked you look
another crispy sock no thank you
oh sniffing that is wrong how many
crispy socks she gonna find though
crispy socks here crispy socks there
crispy socks with some mystery hands
we're gonna turn it off right now come
on you guys we started it we gonna
finish
oh
all the bee changed up
i got the kitchen and the basement and
the living room and since your dad met
that [ __ ] i got his office too got my
juices going my rhymes flowing my breath
blowing showing the signs are slowing i
can feel my skills growing took a little
practice to practice these lyrical
gymnastics but now the fact is queen bee
imma be throwing out your mattress hell
yeah baddest [ __ ] in the biz taking the
show
[Music]
don't you put your hands away
[Applause]
lewis
[Music]
wow
but but
[Music]
poo
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
the space between the button balls taint
face you tainted taint your face is
obtained
[Music]
take it back no i won't take it back i
never win take it back go away
[ __ ] you don't need to fight over me
there's plenty
[Music]
you know what i'm talking about right
y'all know what i'm talking about
oh
[Music]
there's a light
and it shines within the darkness of the
sands of time
from time there's our fight
but the battle to be won is with the man
[Music]
will inside it from getting to you
flying high
to live
like a dream
[Music]
there's a fire
let the music in your heart give way to
the things that you believe
[Music]
[Applause]
exactly
[Music]
[Music]
don't let
[Music]
if you first
[Applause]
[Music]
like a dream
[Music]
i believe
is the power
of wings
[Music]
you should just stay ahead at night i've
had too much wine
leave at first light it isn't that far
maybe just to stay where you are back to
my place
[Music]
i really had a very nice
[Music]
look i really have to go you really have
to stay hey no means no that is what
they all say
you're hurting my eyes
let go of me we can make this harder
just easy
woman always comes prepared ooh i'm
really scared i said this is not what i
want why you have to be such a no
self-defense i dare you to try it i
don't want to fight
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
please just please go away you wanted me
to stay well i i just changed my mind i
think
[Music]
please
too
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
playground with us
[Music]
jet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you gotta make it swim
[Music]
trees
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey what the hell are we saying man i
got no idea man i'm just hungry and
talking about the galaxy and trains i
think they
[Music]
[Applause]
hi i'm ray parker jr writer and
performer of the academy award-nominated
hit single
ghostbusters from the major motion
picture ghostbusters but that's just one
song i've written so many other major
motion picture theme songs and submitted
them throughout the years
now they're available and together for
one specially priced compilation
songs like
you tried to play the game but it's
driving you insane
jumanji
danger in the jungle jumanji
there's lying in my house
come on mr computer
throw me a bone i said lawn mower
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
watch out behind you that's trying to
find you pelican briefs
it's getting legal y'all these songs
have only been heard by the highest
level of industry decision makers but
now you can feel like a hollywood
executive in your own home
i see your face off
that guy walking around it's a face off
that ain't even your face
passing on the christ
get me down off for this cross
[Music]
now there's a whole lot of kinky that
that room is stinky 50 shades of grey
all right white people
who's a slave
i'm not a slave oh
12 years i sang
[Music]
there's one thing i know is that
persistence makes perfection
sure hollywood missed out
but that doesn't mean you have to
down in the basement
what's going on
it's uh
there's a kid and a nazi down
there order now to receive your free
copy of bobby sings the twos theme songs
to sequels that were never made
[Music]
i once met alas so fine she was drunk on
barley wine i'd been to sea for months
or three i knew i could make her mine
and the last was past consent so it was
off with her we went and we threw her in
bed and rested her head and left because
that's what gentlemen do
a woman has a right to a drink
[Music]
[Music]
there once was a gal from leeds who i
heard was good on her knees so i docked
my ship for an overnight trip to take
care of all my needs just fine as the
tails to tell and my mask began to swell
so i laid her down and raised her down
and performed cunnilingus for an hour or
so
[Applause]
[Music]
i once had a woman so fair whose wound
contained my air with a sun by my side
the seas we'd ride the child she would
bear but my girl she was no fool she was
working her way through school so i did
support when she chose to abort because
it's her body in there for her choice
[Applause]
[Music]
talking about a ship we don't say [ __ ]
and we don't say [ __ ] cause that
language leads to things like bodies
there was a lady with a golden eye and
the doctor said she would die so she
emptied her purse to lift the curse and
prayed to stay alive she awoke the very
next day
and in her grave she lay but the
scariest part of the story from the
start is i bet you assumed the doctor
was a man
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Music]
there was a slot with tits to here and
an ass snake
[Music]
cause it's yo ho but we don't say how
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ah
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye
well i'm just a good old american boy
with a heart that's red white and true
dreaming of the girl with the red hair
and freckles in her eyes like the skies
of blue
country music yeah i grew up in texas
you know so all right keep her safe from
the homies in the wrong side of town
where they're smoking the reefer and
acting like clowns
keep that pretty white dress from
getting dirty and brown cause that's the
american way
oh
pretty racist song
racist against who
or black people
black people but i'm black
well
keeping the red-headed girl away from
the homies on the wrong side of town
homies come on brother there's all kinds
of homies you know you white homies
asian homies
no homies are black no i think you're
making them black man i mean i think
that's your stuff you hear the twang
and then you assume that it's racist but
that's that's just what country music is
like here look you're gonna like this
one you'll like this one all right
some folks wear their hats way off to
the side with their pants down low and a
gun tucked inside take their beer by the
40 and their chicken deep fried i think
we all know who we're talking about
[Applause]
the only dark i like is when i turn off
the lights the only hood i love is
pointy and white and trust you if i
can't see your face at night i think we
all know we're dogging up wait wait hey
stop that
that's racist what's what what is racist
about it the only hood i love is pointy
and white yeah man
let's talk about the klan man
the ku klux klan
are you outside of your mind that's
traditional country music imagery man
like a pickup truck or sleeping under
the stars or your dog got killed or your
wife left you same thing i would have
been fine with any of those things what
is the difference between those things
and what is in the song they're not
racial hey you know what can i just say
something man i'm just gonna be frank
you're getting a little like al sharpton
like um farrakhan on me right now man oh
my god
are you serious
dude please hey give me you know can i
do one more let me just do one more dog
i absolutely promise you that this song
is not racist and it's impossible for
you to misinterpret it as such
okay it seems like you're about to sing
the most racist song so far i'm not
how
[Applause]
[Music]
over here trying to sing about a tire
swing
write off an entire genre of music
the banjos are struggling and the drums
are banging let's get the boys together
and have ourselves a hangout oh damn
now i see it
now i see it
[Music]
one at a time
i put men like you behind bars every day
one at a time
you may take my years
but cannot lock my soul away
do
[Music]
don't let me get in your way
[Music]
do i tell him of his
now where did this [ __ ] come from i
have no idea one at a time
it's hard enough to talk to him did you
say my daughter
now this is just a
[Music]
because joke are getting worse taking
what we can from everything
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is the city on fire what's with all the
smoke
oh now we're all ears
[Music]
all y'all rappers out there think y'all
hard cause what y'all been through hey
y'all
check it out it was friday night chillin
on my front lawn me and my crew i had my
bathrobe on everybody high just watched
x-men got plenty chicken heads ready for
sex man monsters roll up they trying to
talk smack don't these know they [ __ ]
[Music]
went back to my palace fast
now i'm the dude walking around with a
phallus cast like wolverine i'm trying
to be a loner but they think i'm got an
adamantium boner what can i say they
still up on my totem pole [ __ ] get your
tongue ring away from the scrotum hole
don't know why they love it but it keeps
the ladies moistening gave half the
honeys in the hood lead poisoning shot
shot shot
i got shot in them
[Music]
still standing
[Music]
that hurts
damn no video over man video's over
i'm serious man
damn
struggling
using words and rhymes to get through
hard times
yeah
come on
[Music]
i came from the streets with nothing in
my pockets no food no picks no power no
sockets each battle i fight a role model
and a teacher hip-hop my church every
rapper a preacher
i preach from my ass my farts is my
sermons the church is your mouth where i
shoot my holy spermin you could take
your role models roll them on my meat
[ __ ] always on the menu when i
[Music]
but everywhere we go we don't forget the
struggle son black woman two jobs two
kids too tired to juggle
[Music]
in my
mouth
different
[Music]
it looks cities we're back together
and it's like nothing had ever
torn us apart
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so tonight i'm gonna hit that
tonight i'm gonna hit fat hit that
tonight i'm gonna hit that pitch
[Applause]
[Music]
just get into my car
and i'll take you so far
from
[Music]
let's just walk and take it slow
in crowded places so they'll know
[Music]
[Music]
tonight
[Music]
i'm sorry
that was an involuntary reaction
hey i just got a text from charles y'all
he got on the wrong bus he's on the
other side of town other side of town
but our concert is in an hour yeah i
know but but he wants us to warm up and
rehearse praise to the lord charles said
that in text okay okay well if that's
what charles said yeah that's okay we
got this we can do what we can do to do
this come on y'all
come on
five six seven eight we lift up to the
lord we give praise up to the lord we
sing merrily up to the lord
give thanks up to the lord
we lift up to the lord we give praise up
to the lord we sing merrily up to the
lord
give face up to the lord
i think you're gone from your note
you're going higher than your note
pretty sure this is my note in fact i'm
positive this is my note because this is
my note pretty sure this is my note
could have swore this was your note that
has never been my note well we can't
have the same note so one of us is wrong
why don't you worry about your note i'll
take care of my own nose but it's a
really really really bad note
you are not taught
i never said that i was charles well you
acting like you thank you charles look i
know that i'm not charles you can't say
that again
well you're both off your notes and it's
messing with the rest of our notes
speak for yourself naima
holding my nose i wasn't trying to
single you out you said everyone was off
that note not everything is about you
gina
kiss my black ass
oh dear lord
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
had this feeling for so long
i didn't feel so right baby how could
this feeling be wrong
sometimes the thing that you've been
searching for
has been right there the whole time
so baby i'm here to tell ya i'm waiting
right here just to make you all mine
you're the one i always hope for
it's a feeling i can't hide you and i
always been here baby standing right
here by your side
[Music]
yes been building up inside of me
and i just gotta come out
and tell you what i'm feeling girl tell
you all love is what i'm talking about
[Applause]
gotta tell you what my heart knows
and what it has known for so long
[Applause]
[Music]
i will take care of you baby
baby let's take our sweet time do it to
you slow the way you've never done
before we're opening up your mind i will
open up your door i've been searching
all around
[Music]
sometimes the thing you're searching for
has been there the whole time
i want to give you all i got now
and i'll take all you can get you
and i'll never turn my back on you as
long as we both shall leave i'm talking
about you
you standing right in front of you
nothing left to hide you sugar sam i'm
telling you everything i've kept very
deep inside
i'm rubbing up against your big bald
head your big bowed head i'll shed your
big bald head and then now there's no
one else i could be possibly talking
about cause you are bald and you are
here
[Music]
you're a woman i'm a man now you
and you know that's how i like it you
and i'm specifically talking bout you
because you're a girl and i am the
opposite of you
woman woman woman woman woman
you are a woman i am a man
you know i like women
[Music]
me to a place i know and ain't no pain
ain't no sorrow it's a place to be if
your skin is brown
i'm talking about negro town
negro town
what like atlanta
almost now be quiet while i sing
negro town you can walk the street
without getting stopped to rest or beat
and there's always a cab when you need
to get around
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's light skin dark skin every shade
[Music]
and there's no white [ __ ] to take
them away
[Music]
this sounds too good to be true it does
doesn't it
i'm sorry i'm sorry
in negro town you live long and well
there's no disease no sickle cell no
stupid-ass white folks touching your
hair or stealing your culture claiming
it's theirs
hanging out in a groove doesn't make you
a gang
every word that you say ain't considered
slag
no one trying to get in on the latest
trend by making you their token black
friend is the place where harmony is
found
it's a
black playground
talking about
talking about
[Music]
oh
[Music]